one step at a time through
Rehabilitation and engagement city of
North Las Vegas is focusing on helping
offenders through its care Court Lauren
Negrete is live in The Newsroom this
morning with a look at four recent
graduates Lauren good morning good
morning you guys that's right the care
Court addresses the root cause of crimes
in low offenders and works to achieve
Social Justice Reform resources and
counseling are provided to help
participants reconnect and engage with
the community one graduate says shares
that she had three traffic tickets went
to jail twice but turns it all around
I'll have almost sea months clean on the
19th of March so um I just got in the
program
um I was just honest with my with myself
and with the judge and just let the
judge know you know that I'm coming from
my background of
um abusing prescription medication
she encourages others struggling to stay
strong and has a great job now the
program connects participants with
transitional housing substance abuse
counseling employment placement among
other resources and the program gets
graduates cases dismissed back to you
guys